un llamado chino a detener la contención
el ministro de exteriores chino expuso
la actualidad de la política exterior
del país y las tensiones con Estados
Unidos fueron El plato fuerte
chingan fue enfático en expresar la
negativa china a entrar en confrontación
con la nación americana y llamó a la
cooperación Aunque el funcionario
advirtió que si Estados Unidos no deja
de presionar a China el futuro de la
humanidad podría estar en riesgo
si Estados Unidos no pisa el freno y
continúa a toda velocidad por el camino
equivocado no se podrá evitar el
conflicto y el enfrentamiento Quién
soportará las catastróficas
consecuencias esta competencia es una
apuesta temeraria en la que está en
fuego los intereses de ambos pueblos e
incluso el futuro de la humanidad china
se opone firmemente a esto
la guerra en Ucrania también fue uno de
los temas abordados por el ministro las
recientes acusaciones del gobierno
estadounidense sobre una supuesta
asistencia militar del gigante asiático
a Rusia provocan indignación en Beijing
chungo
China no ha creado la crisis ni es parte
de ella no ha proporcionado armas a
ninguno de los bandos del conflicto Por
qué se culpa se sanciona se presiona e
incluso se amenaza a China es
absolutamente inaceptable
China y Estados Unidos tienen un
historial de altibajos en sus relaciones
que hoy se encuentran en un momento
complejo debido a posiciones encontradas
con respecto a temas como Taiwán la
guerra en Ucrania y la polémica derivada
del denominado globo espía un escenario
en el que algunos ven sombras de la
Guerra Fría